we're in California a place that's very
open to new eco-friendly technologies to
find out about the future of fuel cells
the idea of using hydrogen to power cars
isn't new Volkswagen has been working on
fuel cell vehicles for over a decade now
the VW Group is presenting two research
vehicles that can soon be ready for
volume production the Passat hi motion
and the Audi a7 H Tron Klaus needs fits
checks out the Passat hi motion first
that's a nice amount he finds driving
this hydrogen powered vehicle to be very
relaxing as Americans put it it's very
quiet and powerful the Passat hi motion
can accelerate from zero to 100
kilometers an hour in 10 seconds
the car is based on Volkswagens modular
transverse matrix platform making it
possible for the engine to be fitted
into the firm's other models such as the
golf
the high motion runs on electric power
thanks to its modular construction its
drive components can be found as usual
in the engine compartment the high
motion fuel cell drive generates the
electricity to power the electric motor
from hydrogen and oxygen
the combination triggers a chemical
reaction whose products are electricity
and water how safe is the technology
many drivers still have concerns about
hydrogen powered vehicles but there's no
need to worry says Klaus modern hydrogen
tanks are made of carbon fiber a
high-strength and time tested material
that's used in Formula one it's much
safer than a regular gas tank made of
sheet metal is desertin all feel feels
each other the hydrogen tanks are found
in the cars underbody so they don't take
any space in the interior an additional
high voltage battery stores the
electricity generated during startup and
acceleration the battery and fuel cell
work together to drive the powertrain
with its three-phase motor the high
motion features a high performance drive
system like all of Volkswagens ecards
howdy has put the fuel cell technology
jointly developed with VW into an a
seventh of the H Tron the H comes from
the chemical symbol for hydrogen on the
outside the a 7/8 Tron looks like a
regular series production model as with
the Passat hi motion the fuel cell is
found under the hood because the car
only emits water vapor its exhaust pipe
is made from plastic this helps reduce
the vehicles weight
and what's our Technic fuel-cell used in
the Audi a7 is identical to the one in
the Passat but the a7 has a slightly
larger battery which increases the
combined output to 170 kilowatts or
around 220 horsepower the a7 h-trans
performance is more than respectable it
Sprint's from 0 to 100 kilometers an
hour in 7.9 seconds and can reach a top
speed of 180 km/h you might think that
this hydrogen powered vehicle is so
chock full of technology and electronics
that there'd be no space for the Audi's
Quattro four-wheel drive system but
that's not Sosa's Klaus the fuel cells
supplies power to the electric motor
that drives the front axle the battery
stored in the trunk runs a second
electric motor providing power to the
rear axle so there's no mechanical
connection between the front and rear
axles but that's not all the a 7h tron
can also run on straight electricity
in fact licensed unlike the Passat the
a7 can be charged using an electrical
cable the car has an all-electric range
of 50 kilometers which is an advantage
for city driving and saves on fuel in
this case hydrogen instead of a rev
counter the aid stron has a power meter
that informs the driver about the actual
power flow as well as the fuel level in
the hydrogen tank and the level of
battery charge the screen in the center
console also provides an overview of
power consumption
Novitsky life owners of electric cars
might ask themselves why they should
switch to a fuel cell powered one the
answer is quite simple fuel cell powered
cars have a long range in this case
around 500 kilometers and are easily
refueled filling up a hydrogen powered
vehicle takes around three minutes
whereas you need two to three hours to
recharge an electric car both mansions
fire authorized on
cause would like to think imagine that
in 10 or 15 years time a car like this
could cost less than a gas or diesel
powered one at least he hopes that will
be the case
haven't seen ax or a diesel vehicle to
minister in Chatsworth it's still
unclear how much such fuel cell vehicles
will cost valuable materials like
platinum are needed to make the fuel
cells and the cars will only be produced
in small numbers to start with so prices
are likely to be in line with those of
the electric and hybrid cars already on
the market but unlike California Germany
doesn't yet boast many filling stations
where people can tank up with hydrogen
at present there are just 16 in the
entire country that number is expected
to increase to around 400 by 2023
but to offer nationwide coverage Germany
would need to have around 1,000 hydrogen
refueling stations